[Music]
biopsy is a procedure to remove a piece
of tissue or a sample of cells from your
body so that it can be tested in a
laboratory a biopsy is frequently used
to confirm the specific type of cancer
apart from bio cancer biopsy can also
determine other pathological conditions
as well
now basically biopsy is removing a piece
of tissue and examining it in the
laboratory now this
tissue removal and examination under in
laboratory
is done to determine certain factors
factors such as the histological and
cytological Analysis which is important
from Clinical perspective whereas
transcriptomic analysis genomic analysis
and proteomic Analysis are important
from research perspective
now these biopsies can tell whether a
tissue sample shows cancer of
procancerous properties or not where the
cancer originates in the body what type
of cancer it is and also the stage of
the cancer
now Imaging tests such as MRI CT scan or
even pet scan are helpful but alone
cannot tell the difference between a
cancer or a non-cancerous condition or
also which particular type of cancer it
is so for that comes the importance of
biopsy now biopsy can be of different
types suppose in the thyroid gland we
have a tumor now this tumor
from this tumor we can excise out a
small chunk now the small chunk of the
tumor can be sent for biopsy or we can
take out the entire tumor and send this
for biopsy it's like taking out the
entire chocolate bar from the wrapper
and sending it for testing whereas
taking a small chunk of the chocolate
and sending it for biopsy or analysis
now this
taking out the entire tumor is known as
excisional biopsy and taking on the
small chunk is known as incisional
biopsy now incisional biopsy can involve
the classical cutting with a scalpel
cutting a small chunk of the tumor and
sending it to the lab or we can use
certain techniques like core needles or
needle based biopsies now this needle
based biopsies sometimes use Imaging
guidance like USG guidance or city
guidance those are known as the USG
guided biopsy or CT guided biopsy now
another type of biopsy that is there
known as skin biopsy now we use a skin
biopsy machine which punch outs the
lesion from the skin as a as a patch and
send this patch with the lesion for to
the lab for analysis
another type of biopsy is known as
endoscopic biopsy in which we introduce
an endoscope in some of the orifices of
the body and that endoscope brings out
the chunk of the tissue for analysis now
biopsy
involves histopathological analysis as
we discussed earlier
now this analysis can help us to
understand the staging or cancer
progression now the biopsy can reveal
whether the tissue is normal or whether
it has undergone hyperplasia dysplasia
or even neoplasial cancer
now cancer cell specific biomarkers can
be analyzed using a technique known as
immunohistochemistry this can supplement
the findings of a biopsy in determining
the exact type of cancer
I hope this summarizes the idea of
biopsy
to get notes and flashcards you can
follow us on our Facebook page or our
Instagram page at animated biology with
arpan the link will be in the
description box below also we need your
support to make free high quality
content for that you can go and
contribute in our patreon page or can
use the super thanks icon to support our
channel the super thanks icon will be in
the bottom right corner of any video you
can contribute using paytm PayPal or UPI
if you wish to connect with arpan you
can use the following links in the
description or for medicine related
content go and follow the nerd medic on
YouTube or you can get in touch with
Ayan of Nord medic through these links
until then bye bye see you in the next
one